monday marks 17 years since hurricane
katrina made landfall along the gulf
coast the city of new orleans took the
brunt of the infamous storm as part of
its recovery which continues to this day
a world-famous artist contributed their
work to the crescent city now as jamie
wax reports there's an effort to save
those creations
this area of new orleans on the eastern
side was flooded earlier today after a
levee bordering an industrial canal
broke during the height of the storm
as we approach the 17th anniversary of
hurricane katrina nice and slow
here's a katrina story you may not have
heard
also a 17
a tale of 17 important works of art
internationally renowned street artist
banksy arguably the most famous and
valued living artist installed multiple
pieces of public art in new orleans
three years after the hurricane as a
tribute to the people of the city though
the worth of the artworks is impossible
to calculate amazingly only a handful
have survived
international house was the first world
trade center in the world that's in
large part due to people like real
estate developer sean cummings it's
visually interesting you have all the
different quotes and secondly you know
this tells the what do you call this
room is this a museum
okay who preserved and restored banksy's
looters mural for the lobby of his
international house hotel we are in
front of
one of the most important banksies in
the world
that you helped restore
and brought here to your hotel
why was that important to you the
remarkable part of it i think is that
one of the most famous artists in the
world
came to new orleans at a time where we
were down and out in the aftermath of
the katrina catastrophe everyone wants
to matter and i think that the 17 murals
or stencils that were painted around the
city in effect said
new orleans matters you matter
before making it into the hotel lobby
the 1600 pound looters mural was almost
lost for good
different street artists
painted over it they put paper mache or
papier-mache
plexiglass threw all kind of stuff on it
obama election posters whatever and
ultimately it was completely opaque
concealed from the public for more than
a year people forgot that it was there
thankfully with the help of restoration
artist elise grenier a louisiana native
who's worked on restoring art at
locations throughout europe
this banksy was safe
we had a chance to talk with elise in
front of what is banksy's most famous
work in the big easy umbrella girl now
what you're doing with banksy
is similar to what you do with
with ancient art forms in europe
is that you're trying to
take them out of their original context
and just preserve them well we have to
sometimes to protect them yeah
now shawn and elise plan to keep on
protecting new orleans remaining
banksies next on their list is banksy's
child with a life preserver the building
where the work was created was
demolished but a dump truck driver with
an eye for art saved the piece and
reached out to sean
we got a sneak peek at the restoration
in a secret warehouse
you are in the process of finding
other banksies and restoring them can
you tell me about that we've been
fortunate to save another one a second
uh of the 17. we're almost finished
maybe 30 more days but we'll be excited
to
share with the public a second
piece of his work that was otherwise
literally
lost to a landfill
or a dump truck what is it about the
banksy
art that really
draws you because i can tell talking to
you this is really a passion for you you
know this famous artist to make a
statement and effectively say you know
this place matters you all matter
and uh and still as he always does with
smart wit poke a finger in the eye of
convention and authority
in as only he can
for cbs saturday morning jamie wax new
orleans
i'm always amazed the work that people
those who restore i was thinking are so
meticulous and the way they i mean it's
something that's completely covered by
other painting graffiti whatever else
and you can bring it back to what it was
it's incredible it is it's it's an art
form yeah itself and those the banksy
works truly are snapshots of time
beautiful work